we tend to think of our experience that
just sort of happening to us
instantaneously so you know I don't
think when I talk to someone that they
are across the room and therefore
there's a certain amount of time that it
takes for me to hear what they're saying
we just think that everything happens in
real time but you know the fact is that
we perceive the world through this organ
in the brain and it works a lot kind of
like a like a telegraph so if you were
to send a message to somebody with a
telegraph and you start tapping out your
your message they're not going to get
the message immediately it's going to
take time for all those dots and dashes
to make their way down the wire and get
to the other end we have wiring in our
own brains we have neurons which work a
lot like telegraph wires in some ways
say they actually use kind of a
biological set of dots and dashes their
little spikes of voltage that we use to
process information so you know if I see
something it takes a while for it to get
from my eye into my brain and then it
takes a while for it to spread to
different parts of the brain and then
for that information to get integrated
in lots of different ways the way that
you can think about this really vividly
was was brought home to me once when I
was talking to a neuroscientist named
Michael Gazzaniga and he just basically
all he did was he took his finger and he
stuck it on his nose and he said you
know it's interesting is that you feel
your finger touching your nose and you
feel your nose touching your finger at
the same time but the fact is that the
signal from your fingertip had a lot
longer to go than the signal from your
nose and yet they got to your brain and
they felt like it was happening at the
same time so so so your thoughts have
this speed and your brain has to to your
brain how to to deal with that that
speed has to deal with that delay
now you might think well you know we
should just have brains that that work
as fast as possible so we should just
have you know fast fast neurons and just
to speed everything up you know because
because time is money because because
you know your survival might depend on a
fast signal there's a problem though is
that speeding up these signals
doesn't come for free so one strategy
that that we have evolved for fast
thought as it were is to insulate our
neurons and this is actually you know
something that is used a lot in
engineering I mean if you don't want to
signal to dissipate out of out of a wire
you you want to insulate it we insulate
our neurons with sort of fatty molecules
like myelin another thing you can do is
that you can actually take another trick
that telegraph engineers first developed
which is to make your neurons thick so
signals will go through a fast wire I'm
sorry signals will go through a fat wire
quickly faster than a thinner wire now
the problem is that insulating your
neurons and making them fat is a big
cost it takes a lot of energy to do that
energy you could be using for other
things and not only that but you know
your brain is a pretty tightly packed
place if you were to you know double or
triple the width of your neurons your
head might not be able to fit through a
doorway so evolution has come up with
these wonderful optimizing trade-offs
our signals work quickly in some neurons
and slower and others we've found this
this nice balance to to speed it up as
fast as possible without making the cost
to too high and the fact is that you
know when I put my nose touch my finger
to my nose I actually don't want the
signal from my nose to go too fast I
actually want the timing to make
everything seem to be happening at once
so actually some time
you need to slow thought down a little
bit in order for the world to make any
sense